[Musique]
super alors le petit exercice
combien de personnes ici peuvent dire
qu'elles ont traversé leur cursus
académique sans le moindre traumatisme
le mot ne doit pas aux empreintes mais
une matière et barbe hâtive vous plaire
car on n'a jamais eu d'intérêt je ne
sais pas combien de fois le calcul des
coûts situe aujourd'hui au quotidien un
professeur qui aurait pu vous accabler
une formation faite par défaut parce que
les parents ont dit les pensons panthier
je vais être banquier ou même une
orientation qui aura savez en déphasage
avec les réalités économiques lever la
main ok je m'attendais à cette réponse
parce que depuis que l'école a été créé
telle qu'on la connaît aujourd'hui
la société a mis en avant l'utilité
économique des personnes avant leur
épanouissement voile à l'école pour
avoir un bon travail avant un bon
travail pour tenir la famille la société
etc
mais est ce qu'est ce qu'on fait de
l'épanouissement de la personne
avant les deux ne devrait pas être un
coup de chance parce que finalement on
est même en indien ce qu'on fait et ça
ne devrait pas être non plus vu comme
l'appétit vient en mangeant donc
imaginer qu'on imaginons ensemble même
n'est ce pas une nouvelle manière
d'apprendre
conçu sur le fait de transformer une
passion en métier transformer un
personne qui est passionné en un
professionnel qui de facto et ultra
profitable économiquement parce qu'elle
fait ce qu'elle aime je ne connais pas
quelqu'un qui est plus productif que
quelqu'un qui fait ce qu'elle aime
vous êtes les informaticiens
généralement une erreur appelle les
guides quand on est dans le noir on mais
n'est pas la lumière on ne mange pas
beaucoup parce que on n'aime pas se
décoller de l'ordinateur petite anecdote
moi quand je préparais mon bac
c'est ma grand-mère qui nous garder à la
maison et elle appelait les parents qui
étaient à l'étranger leur disais je mens
l'enfant là il travaille tout le temps
il est tout le temps devant l'ordinateur
alors que moi je savais pas je verrai ce
que je voulais c'est internet plus de la
nuit et le pau fc comme si je
travaillais alors pourquoi apparente est
donc transformé ce passionné en un
professionnel qui est pertinent
techniquement communicants
viable et gour eux qui est capable vous
soumettez un problème il même si c'est
loin de sa zone de confort et vous
synthétise une solution via le numérique
par exemple c'est ce qu'on attend n'est
ce pas aujourd'hui en entreprise dans un
monde où ça bouge 2.0 3.0 innovation etc
on sait ce dont on a besoin mais pour ça
il faut travailler sur trois axes le
savoir-faire des personnes leur
savoir-être en mettant un fort accent
sur le leadership et le sens de
l'innovation parce qu'aujourd'hui vous
serez pas le millième facebook réseau
social
comment dire à taille humaine et c'est
dans un march rapaille faut innover
et pour ça il faut bousculer les côtes
de l'éducation classique le premier que
je veut bousculer
c'est le professeur enfin non le sachant
parce qu'à différentes formes de sa
chance c'est à dire celui qui se met
entre la connaissance et la prudence
celui par qui il faut passer pour avoir
la connaissance
on va le supprimer de l'équation et on
va demander à l'apprenant d'aller
directement chercher sans connaissance
comment se permet d'avoir un tel culot
pourquoi on fait des choses comme ça on
va se poser quelques questions
le premier la première préoccupation
c'est la créativité
si on décide de faire un exercice là
tous ensemble et qu'on dit et je dis
allez l'assemblée d'eysines et moi un
cercle dans un carré mais avant que vous
n'ayez la chance de faire l'exercice je
vous donne un exemple
je viens de prendre le risque de brider
votre créativité
parce que en tant que ça change j'ai
véhiculer le message qu'ils avaient une
manière de faire les choses
alors que généralement il ya mille il ya
plusieurs manières de faire les choses
correctement
donc au delà de la créativité
on va prendre un autre exemple un
nouveau né j'ai envie d'apprendre à mon
nouveau né comment marcher donc je vais
le tenir debout
je vais faire un peu bouger droite avec
ses pieds jusqu'à qu'ils apprennent à
marcher c'est sa méthode non à ces ça
avait tout nous pas c'est pas ça avait
tout parce que d'un enfant va commencer
à apprendre à marcher vous serez même
surpris
il va pas commencer à quatre pattes se
lever tombé là où l'enfant est un
champion c'est qui peut tomber dix fois
il se lèvera en soi et après il va
mettre en place des mécanismes pour ne
plus se faire mal quand il tombe c'est à
dire tenir le meuble mais vous en tant
que parent vous ne restait pas inactif
vous construisez un environnement qui
adéquat cet apprentissage c'est à dire
que vous mettez des de la mousse sur les
bords des meubles pour qu'il se blesse
pas taillé tombe vous le faites marcher
essayé sur les tapis pour qu'il ne
compte pas quand le carreau etc
c'est dans cette posture là que la
pédagogie dans cette position n'est pas
celle qui fait l'apprentissage pour
l'étudiant pour la prenante mais celles
qui créent l'environnement dans lequel
il peut s'épanouir
pour ça il faut aussi enlever il faut
quand même cassé un autre cote
généralement on fait quoi on vous sert
une base de connaissances que vous allez
stocker tout le long de votre
apprentissage et pour le reste de votre
carrière
une nouvelle pédagogie va prendre le
contraire va vous servir une base de
problème c'est s'occupe pas du fait que
vous savez faire ou pas elle va vous
servir de base de problèmes et il ya
tout plein de mécanismes de socio
constructiviste par lesquels vous allez
passer
donc le coc apprenons ne doit plus avoir
peur d'émettre des hypothèses même si
elles sont fausses en public et il doit
pas avoir peur d'aller passer du temps à
faire des recherches et ne doit plus
avoir peur de de travail et le sur une
fausse piste et de revenir de rebrousser
chemin au dernier moment jusqu'à sortir
la bonne solution il faut le forger à ça
et pour ça il faut aussi enlever les
frictions qui ne sont pas nécessaires la
théorie beaucoup trop de théorie
se baser les disciplines donc l'espoir
qu'ils sont trouvé un du domaine comme
la thermodynamique - d'informaticiens
les et s'appuyer sur le travail d'équipé
parce que c'est ça la paix dit
aujourd'hui on travaille plus seul à
travers une équipe challenge et sortir
de la zone de confort finalement la
présente l'histoire de la doit savoir
respirer la tête sous l'eau
au delà de ça on va aller vers des
compétences qui sont dites ce soft ou
transverses aujourd'hui en entreprise
c'est obligatoire vous ne recruter par
un professeur pour tf1 doit faire le
travail pour lui comme pour recruter
quelqu'un d'intelligent vous voulez
qu'ils disent ce que vous ne savez pas
faire c'est pas pour lui dire quoi faire
sinon c'est pas le bon niveau d'emploi
mais alors
autonomie cette pédagogie doit laisser
les lapins faire le travail activé
s'absorbe son apprentissage aller vers
les rendez vous pédagogique aller dans
les face à face pédagogique être au
coeur lui même de sa formation
elle doit exiger beaucoup de rigueur
parce que vous ne pouvez pas vous
permettre un rêve un professionnel qui
vous rend des choses c'est que vous ne
pouvez pas vous appuyer
des fois les évaluations se font même
par des robots qui ne savent pas tarder
de demi mesure oû manqué de recul je
peux maintenant sur 20 0
on veut alors ça crée beaucoup de
frustration mais la frustration est un
outil si on déduit en la conel sorte de
paranoïa qui va le réveiller à 2 heures
du matin en pleine nuit
pour vérifier si il a bien respecté que
telle ou telle consigne au risque de
voir le travail acharné réduit à néant
la ponctualité une livre de retard le
travail réduits à néant
la sociabilisation 102 lui servira tant
qu'il n'a pas lu ses habits d'être
capable de résoudre tous les problèmes
tout seul dans sa chambre
donc il doit être forcé d'aller vers les
autres fédérer des personnes travers
excès par comme l'autre étant très fière
de travailler l'autre dépende moins le
niveau d'exigence et de différents
niveaux même s'assurer que chacun fait
sa part du travail s'est pas je suis bon
venez avec moi je fais le goût le reste
du travail et vous passez derrière pour
prendre là notre nom tout le monde doit
faire sa part du travail
mais alors rajouter quand même à cela de
la communication et de l'ouverture
vous connaissez tous wozniak steve
wozniak mais je pense et c'est notre jeu
c'est une intuition personnelle que son
génie n'aurait jamais dépassé les
limites de son garage s'il n'avait pas
rencontré steve jobs
qui a été le bonhomme qui a reporté
l'ouverture pour ça on a plusieurs
leviers l'immersion en entreprise
critiques c'est à dire que si vous
voulez avoir un métier demain commencer
tout de suite
actimize n'attendez pas d'avoir le
diplôme pour ramper pour connaissez quoi
l'entreprise immersion en entreprise
travailler avec des personnes d'horizons
différents si vous êtes dans la finance
travers le marketing avec la stratégie
s'ils venaient dans l'informatique
travers le design avec la médecine et
même un outil qui est excellent c'est le
voyage pour l'ouverture de la halle
culte de l'acculturation vous êtes en
france aller en inde
vous êtes en afrique du sud à l'est aux
états unis où aller même en france par
les français fait comme le retard mais
du coup rajouter aussi à tout ce
cocktail là un peu de sérendipité un
environnement où l'étudiant ou
l'apprenant peut innover où il peut
prototype et design et y voit une
technologie qui lui plaît il est une
heure du matin l'environnement et
accessibles de jour comme de nuit
il y va il est capable même s'il ya pas
de l'étude dirais tu veux juste jouer
simple et grands dont il a besoin
il y va il s'exerce et tout ça doit
rester de manière ludique est resté un
challenge de magna ce que jamais j'ai
l'impression de subir
n'est ce pas cette formation et ça c'est
le rôle des animateurs qui sont autour
les parents bienveillants ses parents
bienveillants ont plusieurs challenge le
premier c'est de la distance moi quand
j'avais 18 ans venant du bénin où on a
une telle indifférence pour le sachant
pour le professeur je ne pouvais pas
même si je pensais avoir raison
challenge est techniquement lancer un
débat technique avec un professeur barbu
barbe blanche costume monsieur le
professeur bonjour vous vous vous je ne
pouvais pas il me disait c'est comme ça
et j'acceptais donc les tuteurs dans un
tel environnement doivent les animateurs
doivent casser la distance créer une
relation de proximité avec l'apprenant
de manière à ce qu'ils puissent
s'exprimer dire ces bêtises vous
challenge est pensé avoir raison jusqu'à
comprendre qu'il ne la peau qui n'a pas
raison mais au moins il aura appris
beaucoup plus de choses
autre challenge pour eux c'est de ne
jamais donner la réponse déjà quand vous
venez les voir ils ne doivent pas vous
aider quand votre question n'est pas
structurée je suis un malade mais lyon
mon mal je viens je dis ça ne marche pas
et moi comme un parent trop
bienveillants je vais regarder
ingéniosité pour lui comprendre où ça ne
marche pas non il doit faire ce travail
là et je l'aiderai quand il aura bien
mis le doigt sur la wii bloc et je ne
lui donnerais pas réponse parce que
l'idée c'est quand même de ne pas lui
enlever l'opportunité d'explorer donc je
vais l'aider à explorer mais je lui
donnerai pas la réponse toute faite donc
une telle pédagogie constitue ce qu'on
peut qualifier de pédagogie active et
inductives c'est un peu le contre-pied
de ce qu'on fait là je transmets quelque
chose vous m'écoutez ou pas
mais ça fait ses preuves s'est déployée
dans beaucoup de pays beaucoup de
disciplines différentes différents
niveaux d'éducation et ça produit des
résultats réellement apprécié dans les
entreprises et dans la société en
général
donc aujourd'hui où l'afrique ne peut
pas se permettre de rater les
révolutions qui anime le monde
je pense que une telle pédagogie et d'un
élément de réponse pour relever les
défis du continent
merci beaucoup